[Music]
so is there a way to define science and
separate it from other things
philosophers for a very long time have
been quite dubious about this
possibility and I think that's right
right to be dubious there are all sorts
of things that go under the name of
science there are the Natural Sciences
there are the Social Sciences there are
also various Applied Sciences it's not
really very are easy to find anything
that all of those things have in common
with one another that isn't relatively
banal and also common to many of our
everyday activities so we start off
thinking about of course things like
physics and chemistry and biology and
earth science and so forth but then
there are also the social sciences the
human sciences various branches of
psychology economics and so forth but
it's easy to forget that there are also
sciences that do rather specific things
like the kinds of scientific
investigations people undertake when
they try to restore old works of art or
the kinds of researches that people take
when they they try to figure out whether
a particular document from the past is a
new manuscript by a famous author so
there are lots and lots of scientific
studies and they shade over into
relatively arm familiar things like
detective work and those shade over into
the kinds of things that we do when
we're trying to solve quite practical
problems in our own lives when we're
trying to figure out what goes wrong
with the plumbing or where we've left
something so it's very very hard I think
to say that there's something
distinctive about science that doesn't
also apply to lots and lots and lots of
other activities there are certainly
some ways of criticizing scientific
practice some which I've made myself
but I want to begin with some very
familiar ones I mean some people will
say that the are the science that was
produced throughout much of the history
of science was distorted because it was
produced by a certain class of people
the Royal Society famous one famously
wanted its members to be gentlemen free
and unconfined they didn't like having
trades people in because they might have
a pecuniary interest that would lead
them not to respect the truth and they
didn't let women in until after the
second world war and actually letting
women scientists in makes a big
difference and has made a big difference
to certain areas of science the study of
our primate relatives for example was
enormously transformed are really in the
sixties and seventies as a bunch of
women primatologists really started to
do very serious research and changed our
views about all sorts of things I mean
there was this old view of that you know
there were these dominant males and all
the action was about how the dominant
males got to be dominant and how they
treated other males and all the rest of
it and after women began to look very
very carefully at other features of
primate societies they discovered that
all sorts of things were going on
because of the females influencing the
the mating patterns and the females
would make friends with males that they
thought would be you know helpful and
supportive and this whole view of the
sort of the hyper aggressive primate
beating his chest right was completely
deflated in favor of all kinds of subtle
strategies pursued by both sexes and
that was a complete transformation in
our understanding of primate behavior
it's a wonderful thing to look back and
and see what a difference people like
Jane Goodall Dian Fossey Shirley Strom
and others have made so there's a very
very clear case now there are other
kinds of critique that are sometimes
launched I mean people will sometimes
say look there are all of these
extremely successful non-western
practices that get dismissed by Western
science anthropologists will sometimes
say look how successful this group is
and his belief system seems to be
utterly weird and yet they do very
successfully and indeed Western
scientists sometimes can't replicate
those efforts and I think those kinds of
critiques need to be taken seriously the
one that I think is the most striking is
the the water temples of Bali this is a
very famous example in which Western
scientists tried very very hard to
replicate the armed the strategies that
the Balinese had for assigning water to
the fields and the terraces where it was
needed now the best Western scientific
efforts failed to do as well as the
Balinese system which was dependent on a
system of water temples at which people
would go and engage in rites to the
various gods now on the face of it that
looks like a huge arm you know strange
result these guys are pursuing a
religious agricultural policy and
they're doing better than these
extremely sophisticated Western
scientists and engineers but when you
actually look more closely you can see
what's going on what the problems that
are that the two sides are produced are
pursuing and solving are actually rather
different and what the Western
scientists wanted to do was to set up a
foolproof system that would operate in
the absence of any kind of social
interaction to send the water where it
was needed when it was needed and they
failed in that what the Bali needs do is
congregate periodically at the
areas temples and talk to another and of
course the talking to one another is
really what's doing the trick
not the God's blessing on the on the
watercourse is they they change the ways
in which the water is distributed
according to the needs and the needs are
expressed in social interaction so what
you have here is a two different kinds
of systems and the problem at the end of
the day is that the scientists were
trying to do something much more
ambitious they were trying to get a
solution that would work in the absence
of human interactions and what the
Balinese have gotten very good at use
systematizing human interaction so they
can know where to where to turn the taps
on and where to turn the taps off
basically
but what runs through all of this is a
kind of systematic our way of reasoning
through issues thinking hard about
things thinking what the possibilities
are testing them out in that sense you
might say there's a core that consists
in the scientific method but it's not
something that's just practiced by
physicists or biologists it's practiced
by lots of us a lot of the time in our
everyday lives when we face and try to
overcome the problems that confront us
[Music]